New York, 1922.
The tempo of the city had changed sharply.
The buildings were higher.
Parties were bigger.
The morals were looser and the liquor was cheaper.
The restlessness approached hysteria.
Shall we?
Who is this Gatsby?
Do you know him?
War hero.
Mr. Gatsby doesn't exist.
Gatsby?
What Gatsby?
I beg your pardon.
Mr. Gatsby would like to speak to you, alone.
I'm certainly glad to see you again.
I'm certainly glad to see you as well.
When I made the pleasure of Mr. Gatsby's acquaintance,...
...I discovered a man of fine breeding.
Very interesting.
Everything alright?
Oh yes.
You always look so cool,...
...the man in the cool, beautiful shirt.
She has to tell him she never loved him.
I've just heard the most shocking thing.
It all makes sense.
Will you come, old sport?
We need you.
I wish we could just run away.
Mr. Gatsby, sir.
Not now.
What kind of a row...
...are you trying to cause in my house?
Get the hell out of here!
I wish I had done everything on Earth with you.